50 garlic clove honey chicken wings for
all the garlic girlies starting off with
the marinade for our wings you want to
smash 25 of your garlic cloves with
fresh ginger Gallant oil rice vinegar
and soy sauce evenly coat your wings and
set them in the fridge anywhere from an
hour to overnight to get all flavorful
got this Dracula mincer for the rest of
my garlic because I thought it was cute
but it was not actually that practical
so I'd recommend using a food processor
sauté your garlic in a stick of butter
with ginger until soft and then drizzle
in your honey water soy sauce sriracha
and thicken with a cornstarch slurry
once that's nice and bubbly let it cool
while you coat your wings in flour corn
starch and salt and then fry in small
batteries until nice and crispy toss
your cooked Wings in the sauce better
than I
did and garnish with sesame seeds and
green onion these don't really need a
dipping sauce I just thought it look
satisfying but they are so flavorful now
this is going to be the MVP of your game
day spread